puis en bas là il ya un nouveau quartier
qui s'est refait au bord de l'eau
justement à cause de tous ces
changements qui s'appelle dambo donc ça
c'est le parc secret sous le pont en
fait c'est ça n'existait pas avant c'est
rannou non ça n'existait pas on pouvait
même pas y aller 1 puis maintenant il ya
même un carrousel pour les enfants
qui a été restauré par par quelqu'un en
fait un de nos clients en fait il a
demandé à je pense jean nouvel ou de
paris de lui faire une sorte d'enclos en
verre ce qui fait que les enfants
peuvent y aller en toute saison et être
juste au bord de l'eau sur le carrousel
à l'isoler petits chevaux c'est super
chouette
et puis c'est tout est illuminé le soir
et on peut le voir dupont en fait quand
on prend le train on peut voir le
carrousel en bas avec les enfants il ya
une petite plage et dans le temps les
enfants ne pouvaient même pas toucher
l'eau et maintenant on peut y aller on
peut s'installer
on peut prendre le café c'est très sympa